hi it's bands
i am so happy to be here i am so
excited that you would come here i
wouldn't miss this
well you are really a phenomenon i mean
people
really love your account you have like
shot to superstardom you're always on
the front page of like the trending
instagram
so many kids love you too like you're
all
up in the gen zier oh wow well you know
i always say who would have thunk
because i'm a mom and a grandma of eight
kids
and um this started actually during the
quarantine
so i was watching my grandsons at my
daughters
and at that time they were three and two
years old
so she said mom you'd be great on tick
tock
and i'm like i i love to dance my
granddaughters are super dancers on
there but what am i gonna do
so she said you're gonna do a cooking
show i'm like
i know i'm not and she said you're gonna
try come on just try so i said what can
i cook in a minute
so i did this chicken and potatoes and
lo and behold
people actually watched it they
commented and they started following
so here we are a year later with 300
over 300 recipes on the on our tick tock
speaking of recipes
babs got your recipe box
if that isn't the most soulful beautiful
object i've ever seen
that is treasure when did you start
developing this when did you start
collecting
i started collecting those probably as a
new bride and so
at that point in life there wasn't the
internet so we exchanged recipes a lot
of those recipes are family recipes
that have been handed down or they're
recipes from
friends families that my friends have
have shared
but i have to tell you drew the recipe
we're doing today
is a recipe that was clipped over 45
years ago
this is the newspaper clipping so i
still have it
and i and it's pam's egg breakfast
and i've i've jazzed it up a bit here
and there but
um but anyway this is the recipe we're
making well i can't wait for you to
teach it to me i am your humble student
all right well i hope i live up to your
expectations oh you do
every day i love watching you so much i
can't believe i'm actually cooking and i
can't
believe i'm standing next to drew
barrymore anyway i feel the same way
about you
so we have um eight eggs okay we're
gonna whisk and we're
not gonna make them frothy but just
combine okay
and because um with that we're going to
add
into the milk we're gonna add the salt
and the dry mustard
oh into the milk into the milk and we're
going to whisk that a little bit
just to combine so we're going to pour
that right into the egg mixture
so we're just going to mix that until
it's thoroughly combined and it looks
pretty good
and next we're going to take all the dry
ingredients
and you know this is such a versatile
recipe you don't have to use hollow
bread you could use white bread you
could use like day old bread that's
partially stale
so i use about three quarters of a loaf
of holla and it's already cut into cubes
and then i crumble italian sausage but
you can use breakfast sausage
bacon ham no meat um we're going to pour
that right on the bread
and then about two plus cups of cheese
we're using cheddar
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to pour the wet ingredients onto
the dry
and you know i used to layer this in
years past
and get all fancy and i decided you know
what it's not worth it
so um so now i just mix it up
all together because yes you know the
same uh
end product comes out and it's a lot
easier so you just pour that in then to
this prepared pan
okay and just let her go and then
uh once it's all in you just cover it
with foil
and let her rest overnight and then in
the morning take the foil off
and a 350 40 to 45 minutes until
it's kind of bubbly perfect and then
ready to serve
okay great and now i was like speaking
of may i serve myself
some yes
french time all right oh my goodness i'm
so excited
here's bonus cheers oh bon appetit and i
just salivated
oh this is incredible there's so many
beautiful layers to the bite and so easy
oh my goodness do you have a recipe for
stuffing
oh my word yes or like
i like you know apples and and
uh pecans and like lots of different
things and stuff i would love to
like when we ever have a thanksgiving
all we want is like
stuffing and oh here's another one to
throw your way babs
corn pudding ah a perfect one
we use i use canned corn and
uh in the creamed corn you have to have
the cream corn anyone who doesn't have
the cream corn in there i'm sorry forget
it
doesn't work and plus you need the jiffy
mix yeah
okay can we do that next batch oh yes i
picked corn pudding
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you so much
i want to graduate through any day of
the week okay great let's do that